[Music]
hey
and we're back once again none to worse
for wear
looks like a lot of people are here
already they say see sophie in there
what's up soph
wow she comes by all the time yeah
soph's in here
alex oracle tammy
alex you guys just never get sick of
listening to us yeah
yeah that's crazy it's gonna be a short
one anyway yeah it's just
it's just the sunday yeah it's not like
it's a three-hour show like last night
last night it was full it was four hours
four hours ended up being
yeah like right at four hours i still
have to do the audio like it's not
letting me
sometimes it takes longer like for the
audio to process like
download and put up on the blog and [ __ ]
yeah put the videos up there
i don't even know if we stayed on topic
i don't think we did
yeah but you know yeah i remember
talking about all kinds of stuff
we kind of talked about it yeah we need
to put the [ __ ] loaded level on the
side
as it goes up i liked ken's idea of
doing like well because my idea was like
to do you know a traffic light but can
i think ken had the idea to do def con
and i was like oh okay i like that
better
right yeah [ __ ] up
kind of lose track i didn't do too bad
last night i think i think sophie said i
was just still just at the yellow stage
like i was like
you slurring a little bit but i was
still kind of and i still kind of
remembered although
do you want to hear something funny like
i did this before i left like i wrote a
little note over here on my notebook
that says
you ended the stream and posted this on
instagram
you were fine okay so that i would see
that like
hernandez said it told me to shut it
down that you were starting to slur
[Laughter]
tom shut it down she's starting to drink
yeah it was kind of getting it just
start going in little circles and you
know
where you'll you'll see like kind of
like the you'll say the same thing
four or five times but you say it a
different way each time you say it
that's like the fine art of bullshitting
yeah you're that's how you make essays
tomorrow when you're in school and stuff
like that
you just like say the same thing like
four times
a different
[Laughter]
just shut it off jenny shut it off shut
it down and it shut it down
yeah it was i actually i i had a fun
show like i said we were probably
i think sophie told us afterwards like
you're probably like off topic more than
on but oh well [ __ ] it
i don't care i don't care anymore i
that subject actually what i didn't
think it was all that interesting i got
one a true crime when we need to do
i want to do the north hollywood
shooting yeah remember those remember
the two bank robbers they're all in the
body armor with the machine gun oh right
right right yeah fought the cops for
like
what do you write that down because
otherwise i'll forget yeah that was
hollywood shooting the one
the topic we're doing next week because
like i said the um
the patreon uh polls closed at noon
today
so i know i'm not gonna like spoil it
but i know what the next
week's topic is gonna be in the next
week's movie is gonna be uh so the next
one's gonna be true crime and it was
like
not even close like but i'm actually
glad that we're doing the one we're
doing because i've been wanting to do
that for a really long time and i've
kept and i kept putting in the polls and
like it's kept getting outvoted but it
finally like got
everybody just decided they wanted to do
it next week i guess
um for like the post thanksgiving show
for tour it was mostly about food what
else is new
yeah that's like we all we don't we
really don't eat that much i swear
that's probably probably why we end up
like talking about food so much because
like we're hungry we know we're not
supposed to eat
we're not supposed to eat that much it's
like it's like so we have to just like
talk about it
you say you left it oatmeal cream pie
yeah i got it in here
i got one because you brought backup you
brought two in when you came last night
and you ate one like on the show and
then that's an emergency little debbie
that's it
that's an emergency yeah just in case
they have like this emergency oh i gotta
have that
oh [ __ ] man my blood sugar but yeah so
um
as i mentioned i think i mentioned it
last night on the show
the the movie we're reviewing today it's
a documentary
um i think it originally came out in
2019 and like did the you know rounds of
festivals and stuff but shutter just
dropped it and i guess it's like a
shutter original so i'm assuming that
shutter is the only place you can
see it uh at this point and
this is called leap of faith not the
steve martin movie
uh william friedkin on the exorcist yeah
it was good it was a good documentary i
liked it
this way yeah this was actually directed
by alexander philippe who was the same
guy
who did uh the people versus george
lucas you remember that documentary
which i liked that one a lot he's done
like a bunch of documentaries
he and he did one about the shower scene
from psycho the whole documentary was
about the shower scene
which i kind of want to see that but you
know that sounds like really good
what was the people versus uh george
lucas what was that that was kind of
about
the george lucas fandom and i think it
was about um
it came out like several years ago but
it was kind of about
how um like the backlash against the
prequels right
and all that other kind of stuff um
which i think we were talking about that
on the show last night too like
star wars because we always get off on
that star wars food you know right
um but yeah so this is the same guy that
directed that he's directed like a lot
of
um yeah particularly i guess like he's
particularly interested in
filmmakers and the filmmaking process so
he makes like a lot of documentaries
about that
now this one i will say because i
watched there's not a hell of a lot of
um
reviews of this um at least video ones
like on youtube but one guy
um that i watched they reviewed it he's
like he has a horror channel
and he wasn't real into it he thought it
was kind of boring but um
the thing about it i wouldn't recommend
it to you if you're not
super into the exorcist or if you're not
super into
filmmaking or if you're not interested
in like getting into like the real
um like little details about the
creative process
because basically this documentary is
just
an hour and 40 minutes of william
friedkin talking about
all of his influences talking about the
making of the exorcist i mean
and it goes like into everything like
super in depth like all the influences
he had like other films
um it kind of goes into his relationship
with william peter blatty like how he
found the music for it like all this
other kind of stuff
and so you know they were fighting over
the music
they fought over the music well they
were like all the yeah they were like
all these really i mean william friedkin
and they don't go into this much because
i think there was another documentary
about friedkin that came out a couple
years ago i think it was like back in
2017
and he has a reputation of being i don't
i don't know if i'd call him like a dick
but he does have a reputation for being
real
uh volatile and for doing things
that wouldn't fly today like to get
particular um
performances out of actors yeah slapping
people slapping people smack
um and famously uh both ellen burstin
and linda blair
uh underwent some physical abuse on the
uh set of the exorcist which uh you know
a lot of people know about because it's
like a story that's been told over and
over
um they don't really go into that uh on
this particularly
this is kind of more about just his
whole process of coming
up with you know why the movie is the
is the way that it is and um it's weird
the theme of it almost seems like
i get the feeling that because he's kind
of a religious guy
yeah he goes into the paranormal too
yeah and i
and i get the feeling that he thought
that a lot of things that came together
for the movie for the exorcist were like
fated to happen
yeah like he goes a lot into that he
said he also did some things you know
like
in the first one third of that movie
which is the the setup towards the
exorcist
or the exorcism in the back he said he
did certain things that he didn't know
what it meant
but it worked out like yeah it was
paranormal stuff like
what was it clocks ticking and things
breaking and yeah
and things that were foreshadowing you
know the the uh
pazuzu and finding the pazuzu statues
a lot of that was stuff he just kind of
he said he just kind of pulled it out of
his ass in a way
but it worked i i think i think you know
i talk about a lot of talk about the
unconscious yet a lot yeah and i think
he was doing he's pulling a lot of that
stuff out of his unconscious oh yeah big
time because
you know who who is that who is that
psychologist that wrote all that stuff
about that
um that your unconscious is actually far
more creative than you
oh [ __ ] you guys know who i'm talking
about
he's uh he's famous he's kind of like a
young yeah you know
paul young he's doing a bunch of jungian
stuff
which uh you know we ought to do
something on young
because oh yeah that's actually yeah
write that because
there are some people that were involved
with that dude that swore up and down
paranormal [ __ ] happened around young
and that young could do
or young would inspire you to do things
you know
he'd write things in a book and then you
try to move inward and go inward into
your consciousness and access other
parts of your consciousness
and like people would reported
paranormal stuff
and we're not talking about you know
just laymen we're talking about scholars
and stuff you know real reputable people
said yeah
i kind of saw something that was going
to happen and it happened or you know
i felt a presence and you know did you
you heard about that right yeah
yeah that'd be a good show yeah i'll
write i'll put it on my little thing and
put it in the box
he was working on some kind of book it
had a bunch of weird drawings in it do
you know what do you know that
i'm not sure you know okay you have to
do some research on it
i just remembered he was working on some
kind of a book that was a bunch of
drawings that had come from the
subconscious
and i don't know if he ever finished it
but evidently some
people reported some paranormal or
mind-altering effects
when they uh got involved with that book
and they read it and thought about it
it's weird yeah but like i i don't know
that much about it i just
heard about it in passing yeah you know
what i mean so maybe we need to do a
show about that do you
i don't know if anybody in the comm in
the comment section
knows what i'm talking about it was
mentioned on a documentary about young
yeah this stuff well like i said it's
been a long time since i've read
anything about him so
i wouldn't really know that if he if you
got into a certain mindset weird [ __ ]
would happen it sounded like poltergeist
stuff
yeah very similar i see a couple people
in the comments like uh
like tila and mega badger have watched
this documentary uh already and really
loved it
yeah i found this like really um
engaging you know what i mean it's just
like i was fascinated by because i'm
fascinated by other people's like
creative process
and so the fact that he went into all
these little details and he was just
kind of going how
all of these things sort of came
together like he said almost in a
supernatural way but like i said he
i think he kind of attributes it to
supernatural maybe like that was the
implication that i got
but like you said i think that he is
such a student
of film and art and music and things
like that
that it's almost kind of like he's just
pulling these things like he's
unconsciously doing it yeah back when i
used to draw a lot
i would [ __ ] sometimes just make
these fantastic [ __ ] drawings of the
human figure and when and i don't even
i i didn't remember drawing them you
know what i'm talking about it's kind of
like you go into a trance and you're
just drawing
well yeah i i've always liked this
another part of you is doing it and then
when it's
when it's done you can't remember
actually how you did it i've always
found that my best
um short stories were written when i
wasn't really thinking about it
when i was just kind of like right and
wrong without like almost like automatic
writing right
i mean young has talked a lot about that
kind of stuff yeah and your
consciousness can get in the way
it does of your creative abilities yeah
if you're thinking about it too much it
[ __ ] it up that's letting the force
flow yeah yeah that's what they're
talking about and that's why it took me
so long to really like get
into like fiction writing and stuff like
that because i always wanted to write
fiction but i feel like i was
getting in my own way too much when i
finally like
just said [ __ ] it and i'm just like not
even gonna think about it i'm just gonna
put a pen on paper and just like start
writing [ __ ] it came out
a lot better yeah um you know what i
mean so victor asked how long is it i
think it's about an hour and 40 minutes
roughly it's a very good documentary
about how film
is made about cinema well yeah i mean
this guy
i mean he had how it's really done not
how they do it today
it's not corporate [ __ ] artistic
stuff go ahead he talked a lot about
um like i said he talked a lot about his
relationship with william peter blatty
like i said this dude
is you know very famously
uh he i guess he doesn't like [ __ ]
people so like
william peter blatty i don't know if you
guys know this story
the guy that wrote the novel um he also
wrote
a screenplay treatment and gave it to
william friedkin because they were
friends
and basically he told william friedkin
hey i will give you my percentage
of you know the money that we get for
like the rights or whatever
if you will cast me in this movie as
father karis because father
charis was based on william peter blatty
like he wrote himself into the story and
that was him
and um so basically i mean
freaking like apparently reads william
peter blatty's screenplay
and is basically like not in so many
words but he's like this sucks and
it needs to be like rewritten even
though he'd written the book but it's
like writing a book and writing a
screenplay or two different things as
you know as we've talked about many
times so i do feel like that there was
that whole thing
now originally something else i didn't
know too was that originally they had
cast
uh stacy keach right as father karis
yeah
he was already cast it was a done deal
you know and everything
and then freakin saw jason miller
uh who actually at the time he hadn't
been in any movies or anything like that
it was just like a pr
a playwright and he was in you know he's
like a theater actor
and so uh you know fred can happen to
see
jason miller in one of his own like
performing in one of his own plays
and he thought that he's like that's
father charis and i don't even care that
we
so they had to pay stacy keach off
because he thought he got the role and
he's like sorry man we found somebody
else who left them like that must have
been like a funny conversation
but yeah i got to answer some questions
yeah oracle's
oracle yeah you got it the book i was
talking about was uh the red book
carl young's book yeah i remember
hearing there was
some people reported some kind of like
paranormal
type events around that book after they
had read it and i don't know if they
were if they were taking any
mind-altering drugs which i think
sometimes they did
but evidently um that book involved
that book had a bunch of writings in it
and a bunch of drawings
and they said that it could kind of
affect you i don't know somehow
get you in touch with get you in touch
with the collective unconscious
and uh basically kind of
there's a situation kind of like you
hear about ayahuasca
yeah you know what i mean coming in
contact with you know extra dimensional
voices or imagery and beings and
alien souls and [ __ ] like that i'm
really interested in that kind of stuff
um i need to i need to uh find out more
about that
well yeah like i said as soon as we're
done i'll write it on because i like i
said i have this little thing that
happens
that has like all these little colorful
things and i just write all the
recommendations for movies or whatever
and i throw them in the little box so i
can like put them in the polls or
whatever
yeah um yeah but i like that guy's
director i think he's up there with kind
of like kubrick kubrick did similar kind
of [ __ ] like that but
those you know kubrick was actually my
favorite one kubrick did some really
cool [ __ ]
i mean kubrick and david lynch are
probably my favorite directors i would
think
i don't know enough about david lynch
he's doing that surrealism
see i love that guy yeah she kind of i
don't know no not i'm not too much into
it
well a lot of his movies he's like
quackery it's not though
i mean he's doing the same thing as
friedkin was talking about in this
documentary david lynch is basically
like
well i'm just gonna put whatever i feel
in there and we'll work it out later
and it and it generally does like work
out as something
yeah um so he's like very like intuitive
like he doesn't worry too much about you
know plot coherence or anything he's
like i'm just gonna like
work and you know much like friedkin
because uh william friedkin talked a
great deal in this about
uh citizen kane which you know obviously
one of his favorite movies
and another movie from 1955 which i
think is called ordet
or something like that and uh he talked
about civil lake ingrar bergman a little
bit too
um so they're students of not only
other filmmakers but they're also
friedkin in particular is like a big
um he was a big like art history guy
like he talked uh
you know a bit about caravaggio and
rembrandt's paintings like rembrandt's
portraits like
how that inspired his lighting um in
various films
and he also talked a lot about music and
the funny thing about this he was
talking about the exorcist and he's like
now
because you know most people who know
about filmmaking know that when you do
your rough cut um you usually just put
in
whatever music like in the background
that you want like the director and then
they
you know give that to whoever the person
is that's going to be doing the score
for them
because this is kind of what i wanted
you know kind of what i had in mind
and what ended up happening with this is
that friedkin was like i don't like
scores that tell you how you're supposed
to feel like in the movie
like he's like i don't like these kind
of emotional cues and stuff like that
like in the music
he's like i wanted something a lot more
subtle
and like a lot more and like some parts
that didn't even really have any music
or even some music that wasn't really
music he was talking about like
where stravinsky's like write a spring
and like all this layered like how it
kind of like
built on itself so he was talking a lot
about that
and then what ended up happening was i
guess the first guy
because he had put all these pieces of
music in there like that was similar to
what he wanted
and then they gave it to um the guy that
first guy that did the score
and freedom was like no i hate it it's
like that was exactly what i did not
want
and it so happened he's like i wanted
something more like
a lullaby or something but then he just
happened to come across you know the
very famous mike
mike oldfield piece tubular bells and he
was like
that's it that's what i want so they
were like able to get the rights to do
that and
yeah that shit's iconic and it's yeah
it's like everybody thinks of that
[ __ ] we even had that on vinyl in my
house as a kid well it doesn't
it doesn't tell you how how to feel but
it's if i it's emotionally evocative
that's what he wanted
it encourages you to do something but it
doesn't tell you to do it we still have
the
i think we have the exorcist don't we
yeah i want it makes you want to see
that [ __ ] again
i definitely do want to watch i mean
just watching it i mean
the way that and some thing that he
said in there that really struck me
because he he's like i tried to be
subtle about this so you probably didn't
notice until i just said it and
you're like oh yeah i was like yeah
you're right i didn't notice
he's like there are so many shots in
this movie that are purposely done
to evoke ascension he's like people are
always like walking
upstairs or like you know these shots of
like people
going upwards um and once they kind of
like
edited it all together i was like holy
[ __ ] that was like a
motif that i hadn't really noticed in
that movie so i thought
that this documentary i mean not only
because i was you know like geeking out
about like all the art history stuff
because i love that kind of [ __ ] and i
love
you know creative people talking about
you know
[ __ ] that they like and like where they
get their inspiration from so that was
already really fascinating but you know
the exorcist being
you know easily one of my favorite
horror movies that i've seen many times
and it's really cool because listening
to him talk
it you know to such depth about it
really gave me like a new appreciation
for it and like you said it makes you
want to like watch it again
they talked a lot about mercedes
mccambridge too like the woman that did
the
the demon's voice you know they talked a
lot about that
but um a lot of the stuff that he said
in this was stuff that i hadn't known
about the movie because i do know a lot
of things about the movie like i said
about
linda blair getting hurt and um you know
and ellen bursting getting hurt that one
particular scene where she gets thrown
across the room
um and you know friedkin being kind of
like you know punching people to get
like
shooting guns off on the set like to get
certain reactions and
uh stuff like that so i knew about that
they went a little bit into that but
the [ __ ] that he was talking about on
here was like a lot more
i guess a lot more nebulous like a lot
more like from an artistic standpoint
and i found it like really really
interesting it was good i yeah i found
it really fascinating like i said if
you're not super into the exorcist
you're not super into like creative
creative filmmaking stuff um
because it's basically just him talking
the whole time and then they cut in
you know scenes like what he's talking
about and stuff like that so it's not
like
a bunch of talking heads like talking
about the exorcist it's him
talking about the exorcist for an hour
and 40 minutes you know
and yeah saying she's gonna watch it
again it made her want to see it again
yeah it's like i i kind of wanted but i
don't know if we'll have time tonight
but maybe tomorrow night
yes so tila saw the hand she likes a
hand yeah
she like i i don't know did you like
heavy metal i don't think she really
mentioned it
because i think she said she liked heavy
metal and
i think and i don't know if she watched
the island
yeah maybe she said to do because she's
been reporting back which ones
she's been watching that we recommended
you know what was that one that we
mentioned uh
yesterday the um the what about the dead
people
dead embarrassing because i said that i
saw that big frame poster in the
bookstore that i was at yeah if you
haven't seen dead and buried you
probably like that one too
that was a [ __ ] weird flick that
might be on to be i mean i'm pretty i
think it's on shutter but i think it
might be on 2b as well
unless i'm maybe i'm crazy i don't know
but um
but yeah i i would definitely definitely
recommend this if you're
at all interested in the exorcist or
interested in like the filmmaking
process
yeah yeah because it does go a lot into
and he talks a lot about music and he
talks a lot about his artistic
influences and stuff like that so that i
mean
bergman flicks yeah yeah so like if that
sounds like something that'll bore you
to death then
then don't but but other than that like
i found it
just fascinating like from start to
finish i liked how he went into the went
into the paranormal and he didn't
discount it he said
he just didn't know it's the unknown
well he's kind of a religious guy i mean
you know what i mean so
he so it's not something that's not that
doesn't
that's good for me yeah i mean i i like
religions
i know what they are you know what i
mean they don't
that it's mythology in a way
but that doesn't mean that certain ideas
in them aren't true
you know there's some of those are
universal concepts yeah but afterlife
you know which i think there is an
afterlife you know i think there is a
thing like a god but
my version of it probably more like the
force
yeah i'm like if i'm gonna go because
i'm you know like i'm pretty
like you know i'm pretty atheistic but
if i was gonna go anywhere in that
direction
that's about as far as i would go i
don't think that there's any kind of
like a being of like an intelligent
being
see there necessarily the greeks and the
persians and the
mesopotamians they all believed in
basically titans
giant people in the sky that walked
around and had things
if you look at genesis what they're
describing
is a giant man who's god he has a garden
out in the middle of the [ __ ] desert
and he's made gardeners to take care of
it
and he what it says he walks around in
the coolness of the day
you know tries to cool off in the garden
so they're talking about a titan yeah
you know a big
giant man you know
i don't believe it's not gonna be that
it's not gonna be a big giant middle
eastern potent tape you know
he's created the universe you know i
think that's kind of far out you know
just like like godzilla's stomping
around yeah
well that's basically what you're
talking about is they're talking about
the same thing on mount olympus
there's a mountain that's tall enough
where there's giant
[ __ ] humanoid people
you know his wife and all his children
and they're coming down
cracking the mortal women and making
demigods and that's exactly what uh
that's exactly what
um the old testament the new testaments
are talking about
yeah by the greco-roman standards jesus
would have been a demigod
just you know his mother was a mortal
woman his father was zeus basically
you know they're talking about perseus a
guy like perseus
you know and uh we know that doesn't
happen but that happened all the time in
greco-roman
mythology you know god come down and
get you knocked up and then you have his
kid and that and that and he was like a
nephilim
yeah that's what they're talking about
yeah cow's balls just mentioned nephilim
nephilim
yeah demigods has anybody ever made a
move i mean this is a dumb question
because i'm sure somebody probably has
has anybody
ever made a movie would have that had
like a
godzilla-sized jesus in it as like the
antagonist
like no i think i think in the book of
john though it says that you know when
jesus came out
when it describes the scene where jesus
comes rolls the [ __ ] stone out of the
way and a huge cross comes out and
announces him and then he's
comes out of there and i think it says
he's pretty big
and he goes to heaven everybody's like
pimping yeah
each each gospel is a different story
they sound the same if you
read one after the other because you've
kind of forgotten all the details but if
you read them
side by side they're very different yeah
they're different authors
and they're not talking about something
that happened historically
it's it's it's very much like
greco-roman mythology
yeah it's like fanfic it's like they're
they're riffing on a common theme yeah
yeah well just like superman yeah
superman comic books
you can reboot that story over and over
and over again it's still superman but
the stories are slightly different
yeah you know you got chris reeves
superman you know
you got the new this new superman are
dealing with now you know
just you can tell that story different
ways
and yeah that's what they're doing they
just it's a they got four of them in
there like a best of
like the greatest hits yeah a collection
of the greatest
stories about jesus is what they're
talking about and there's four
because there's four corners to the
earth probably yeah
the four pillars that the earth stands
on like it does
yeah the earth is fast standing on some
pillars
nobody knows where the pillars are
standing on turtles yeah all the way out
the waters
and then you know you got the waters of
the ocean and the waters of the sky
because we know that [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
all blue and we know it goes up into the
air you look up you see blue water
and when it rains it's falling yeah you
open up the
opening up the waters of the sky and
here it comes
it all makes sense when you're inside
the metrodome you're in a dome
[Laughter]
every time somebody says fundament it
just makes me think butthole
i don't know why fourth drawdown said
clash of the jesus see i would totally
totally watch that
you know they they chain andromeda to a
rock and
it's instead of the kraken coming out of
the [ __ ] water it's jesus coming out
of there and then he eats her or he
tries to
somebody better have made that movie
that's all i'm saying
but yeah so it seems like uh you know
the people that have seen this
documentary
already uh are really into it and i was
also really into it so
you know um are you done yeah with
whatever it was that you wanted to say
yeah all right yeah so tila said she
just added dead and buried to her
watchlist as well yeah i
really like that movie it's like it's
pretty weird and it's like
i guess yeah it kind of it's okay it's a
zombie movie but it's unlike any other
sort of yeah
it's it's kind of like that but not
really yeah i really
i really liked it yeah it's creepy it
killed me as a kid i just found it so
strange that
the only movie poster in that bookstore
happened to be for that movie which i
thought was very random and
interesting yeah i was just like huh
okay that's weird all right so
uh i guess we'll shut it down for the
day
and we will be back tomorrow to talk
about another movie
i don't know what it's going to be yet i
got a couple ones written down for
possibilities but we'll see where it is
so uh thanks everybody for dropping by
and we'll see
you guys again tomorrow bye